[Music]
hey what's up on today's show we're
going to be talking about trauma in
first responders
we're going to be talking about
compromising in marriage we're going to
be talking about online dating
we're going to be talking about
self-sabotaging impulse behaviors
and what we can do about it stay tuned
hey what's up i'm john and this is the
dr john deloney show
where we take your calls about your life
about the things going on in your homes
and in your workplace and in your hearts
and minds
here's what i want to do i want to help
you rethink re-examine
reconsider your lives how you talk to
yourself how you talk to your kids
how you talk to those you love those
that you don't like
how you learn to to think about the next
right thing to do
and we're going to talk about love we're
going to talk about loss we're going to
talk about family issues heartbreak
we may talk about people who walk into a
public restroom
and they see a whole wall of empty
urinals or empty stalls
except for one the one you're using and
they decide
i'm not gonna go to the other side of
the bathroom i'm gonna go right
freaking next to you right next to you
12
inches away you could go to the other
stall or the other stall
or way down to the urinal down there but
nope
now i want to i want to pee right next
to you
so we may talk about those folks too you
want to change the world
skip a stall that's what i want
somebody's 20 20
uh presidential slogan to be vote me
i encourage everyone to skip a stall i
would vote for that person
today right i would leave the show and
go vote for that person whatever anyway
whatever's going on in your home in your
heart in your head
for those of you who are wondering wow
i've never thought about skipping a
stall before
i never thought about it peeing in the
other urinal call me 1-844-693-3291
that's one
eight four four six nine three three two
nine one or you can email me
at ask john ramseysolutions.com
it's ask john ramseysolutions.com let's
go straight to the phones just go to
brian in wasilla is it wasilla did i say
that right
that's right westville alaska this is
ryan wow that's fantastic ryan how we
doing good man
good dr john how are you doing i'm doing
well doing well
how is it in alaska i'm gonna just take
a random guess and
think cold and pretty dark is that right
uh yeah this is a nice time of year we
still got some leaves on the trees and
it's getting pretty cold but no snow yet
very cool man
i have romanticized alaska something
fierce and so i'm just going to
stay with my with my fantasy of it and
then we can go from there
so brother how can i help you awesome
yeah it's it sounds awesome
i have a two-part question i've been a
firefighter for 18 years and mental
health is just not something
that we've ever really talked about in
my career nope and in the past few years
it's become the number one killer of
firefighters and paramedics that's right
so my question is one how do i
personally
build resiliency and help my brothers
and sister firefighters
and then two is there seems to be a very
small number
um of firefighters that are kind of
using this to seek i don't know if it's
like a medical retirement or work comp
and trying to get out of the fire
service altogether instead of working on
the issues
and that kind of makes it harder for the
rest of us to get services and help each
other
if we burn those bridges with the people
you know the administrations that are
there to
help us and want to see us whole
so let's go to the first part of that
question um
not speaking for anybody else but just
yourself tell me about your mental
health journey as a firefighter for
almost two decades
yeah i guess when i first started i was
pretty just
type a personality and it was just goes
with the job and all the
firefighters that i worked with and
learned from had been doing it for a
long time and
you just see things and you move on you
do your best
you know you constantly say it's not our
emergency we're just gonna help
and then now after a longer time of
doing it you realize that there's this
cumulative effect
and you know i'll find myself after bad
calls or whatever like you'll just hit
these real
big lows where you know you'll just be
going about your day and then i'll just
wind up on the floor in my pantry crying
thinking about a call or
especially ones that involve kids you
know i have five kids
and um so you're trying to balance this
work
life balance and so it's definitely been
something that has affected me more the
longer i've done the career and the more
that you see
as far as at the beginning of my career
it didn't really seem to bother me much
or i didn't really know
you know one way or the other i guess
so i want to talk about the big picture
and then we can walk back and look at a
few ways that you can help
that people around you can help and then
don't let me forget here but i do want
to talk about the administrative issue
here at the very end
folks who are retiring who are walking
away so i don't know if you know about
my journey but
one of the things i did especially the
last few years was i spent time working
after hours
in the middle of the night with
sometimes with firefighters but with
police departments occasionally with
swat teams
doing crisis response not as intense
and as repetitive as recurring as your
job
but it was showing up to somebody's
house in the middle of the night and
helping with a death notification or
sitting with somebody who just lost
somebody or showing up to a car wreck
and helping somebody's
family get to the hospital where they
could you know pronounce somebody who'd
passed away
or or or or right and one of the things
that
i became very interested in was this
idea of secondary traumatic stress and
you may have heard that
surely after a couple of decades you've
heard that it helped me redefine what
trauma was and what stress was
and for those listening we often think
of trauma as an acute thing right you
were in a car wreck or sometimes we know
that i saw a car wreck and that that
hurts to see that
what we often don't think about is
trauma can also be withholding something
that's positive
right it can be a neglect of something
and so you have kids whose parents don't
talk to them kids whose parents
don't don't interact with them don't
touch them that's a trauma too
but that happens over time and you
mentioned it and i'm so glad to hear you
say that because that's usually a big
eye-opener for firefighters for police
officers for
lawyers for teachers for folks who
regularly work
in the business of other people's pain
is that trauma is
cumulative so here's the analogy i use
and um when i'm when i'm teaching folks
and when i'm describing this
is that we all have a backpack and we
all have our own traumas
that can be cinderblocks if we have
childhood abuse or they are regular
bricks from
poverty or they are bricks from systemic
uh racism issues or whatever things
happen to affect you and then if you
work as a firefighter
what you have decided to do what you
have taken on your heart and mind as the
as a profession
is you get in the lives of other people
and you take their bricks from them
right you go into their worst darkest
moments and you hold their bricks
and if we don't have a plan for how to
put those down
it will bury us right and so what you're
describing
is a textbook example of somebody who's
been in something for a long time and it
has worn you down to the point
that you just find yourself sitting in
the floor in the dark crying because
it's just weighing heavy heavy heavy on
your soul right
so in your particular fire department
what's it like
if you were to tell that story are you
allowed to bring up mental health issues
is everybody
tough guys and tough girls or is it it's
a culture shifting
i think we're right at the beginning of
a culture shift
you know the iaff has created a peer
support
which is a 40 hour class and some of our
people have gone through that training
but there's really nothing formal
there's no
real process other than i mean the
classic is you know
you sit on the tail board with one of
the guys or gals you work with and you
just kind of talk through things as more
what
what happens with the people you're
closest right they're like those uh
tasters choice moments right like the
yeah the everybody has a coffee and a
cigarette and you hug and say that sucks
we'll go get them tomorrow right and
then
it's supposed to all be something like
that right so i
i i this is a passion project of mine
you didn't even know that you just
stumbled into it
but policemen physicians dentists
ministers counselors ems folks firemen
military business leaders teachers
financial planners this idea of just
suck it up this idea of quit being a
baby
that's just the way this job is you got
to deal with it that is
bullcrap and it's hurting people and
here's where it hurts
everybody is it doesn't just hurt you my
man ryan it doesn't just hurt your
family
it hurts the people that receive care
from you
it hurts people that receive care from
your partners and your fellow
firefighters and the ems folks that show
up on scenes and the police officers
show up on the scenes we are living
in a in a world of people walking around
with secondary trauma all over the place
and the idea that you're just going to
roll over and get over it is ridiculous
it's just ridiculous it's stupid and it
hurts people man so i want to tell you
high five you from no i'm gonna hug you
dude i'm gonna i'm gonna post covet hug
you from
nashville to alaska and say i'm excited
i'm glad that you're thinking about this
so here's a couple of things just to
think big uh and these are analogies
brother that
just worked for me number one is
if you work in the messy brokenness of
other people's lives
100 chance i don't care who you are
you will be affected period some people
are affected
and they medicate with food with alcohol
with distance some people just try to
grind it out some people
have 17 other jobs that they work on the
weekends and on their days off
that they try to chase this stuff down
with busyness some people rage out some
people fill in the blank
it will affect you the way i
i described it to myself was this i was
a sanitation worker
and every day when i got done working in
the city sewers
i had to go hose my boots off and i had
to hose off my
clothes before i went into my house i
didn't want to take that that stuff
inside
and i didn't want to um get my bedroom
all messy i didn't want that stuff to
get on my kids and on my wife
but that didn't mean i didn't still need
to do the work somebody's got to be down
there doing sanitation work and it's
honorable
and it's good um can i tell you a funny
story about my old man
yeah so he was a homicide detective and
a swat hostage negotiator
like an absolute stud like a bad dude
and one day
during uh when i was a kid i'm just
gonna say i was 10 or 11. i went to
little league practice in our
our quaint little suburb north of
houston and i left the back door open
um when we got home i left the back door
open just wide open while we were at
practice we were probably gone an hour
hour and a half
we got back and i'll never forget my dad
looked at me
when we got back in the door was open
and he had this look of just
washed fear come over him and he pulled
out his gun
and went and cleared the house
room to room in our little suburban
house making sure it was safe for the
family
and i remember thinking as a young kid
whoa that seems a bit
much right but here's the thing
a hundred percent of my dad's day was
dealing with
that very rare moment that it happens to
somebody else
right and so his bell curve had shifted
and so what folks who work in the messy
ugly lives of other people have to
constantly be on guard about is
right not letting their bell curve shift
so here's a couple of things that have
helped me brother
okay um number one you've got to have
people in your life that you trust
and i would strongly prefer them to not
be firefighters
or police officers or ems people because
you don't tell each other the truth
right you minimize it a little bit or
you over sensationalize it a little bit
and having a professional is a really
remarkable thing
that you can go sit down and talk to i
also know that for certain professions
it's nerve-wracking because people write
that stuff down and then people are
worried about that's there's a record of
that somewhere is that going to impact
something am i going to get sued over
something
you got to have somebody that you talk
to the second thing is is you have to be
very very open
with your supervisors and i know that's
a whole other can of worms because
supervisors like to act like they're
tough sometime in bravado there are some
awesome folks throughout the country i
got to work for one
in lubbock but having some folks that
you can talk to
the third thing is is really being
careful about using your wife
or your kids or your family members as
trash receptacles as places where you
come dump that stuff
right okay and then the fourth thing is
making sure you have a
iron-clad never gonna move on it
self-care plan that you that you have
before you get into some of these things
which means you've got to eat right
you've got to have a group of people
you've got to exercise
you've got to meditate and have a
spiritual sense about you've got to have
a relationship with a
with god you've got a relationship with
something bigger than you and you've got
to have practices
that give you resilience that build in
health so that when these things happen
um you've got the fortitude and the
resilience built in
and then the final thing is this i think
i just said final thing there's one more
final thing
okay you've got to be really really
graceful
with my new friend ryan
so like you i i found myself crying some
nights
i committed the unforgivable sin i
walked into a situation i used to have a
phone and i'd get a police code it would
say 108.7
which was a police code for somebody had
passed away and it'd have an address and
we'd show up and it would often wouldn't
know what we were walking into
similar to you guys and i walked in and
it was a young child and i had just had
a small daughter
my daughter was a little bitty and i saw
the child and i looked at my partner and
i committed the unforgivable sin in
crisis world i looked at my partner and
i told her it's she's the most wonderful
partner ever denise smallwood i hope
she's listening she's a saint
she's an extraordinary woman but i
looked at her and said i gotta go
i'm out and i left her and she said i
got you
because that's you know when you have a
good partner that's the way that works
but i left her
because i couldn't do it i couldn't see
a young kid in the situation that this
young kid was in
and so you've got to know yourself and
you've got to know your own limits and i
know it's hard as a firefighter but
you got to know your limits and i had to
go grieve it i went and talked to
somebody about it
i had a small that's going to sound
ridiculous i had a small funeral for
that kid in my head
and then i was able to put a period
within that sentence that was my hose
and my boots off and then i was able to
go back in but i had a
process on the back end for how to deal
with the stuff i had just seen i
couldn't just let it go let it go let it
go
right um what is your when you get home
from a hard situation
you get home from a messy messy
situation you've seen somebody
pass away you guys are trying to help
somebody have a car wreck and they don't
make it
you guys go into a home and somebody
doesn't make it or you just see the
family huddled in the front yard and
watching their house burn down
what is your process when you get home
i usually i just i go to the gym
i just work out until i can't see
straight
and just really you know just take
myself to the physical
limit and then usually that
kind of helps me hit that reset and but
usually there's a real big low
that follows any of those highs you know
where you're making decisions and you're
engaged and you're active
and then the next day or two or
sometimes a week
you know i'll just feel this real valley
that i'm in
and just kind of working through that
but the the physical side of it is
definitely what i
go to or i find um that it just makes me
feel better
so that that's a i'm super glad that
that's the default setting for you
i want you to be careful about that
becoming your numbing addiction right
yeah it's a healthier it's healthier
than going to the bar and drinking it
away right until you can reset that
right
but it can also be an addiction here's
what i want you to practice and then i
want you to promise that you're going to
email me back okay
okay it is mid-october i want you to
um or it's even late october now i want
you for the next month the next 30 days
i want you to go to like walgreens or
whatever little stores there
in alaska and i want you to buy a spiral
notebook it'll cost 99 cents or two
dollars
and i want you to every night that you
get home before you
check out and you leave the station i
want you to write down
what you experienced and i want you to
write down a two or three sentence
little prayer for the family
for the third person and tell them thank
you for your life
thank you for honoring me and letting me
be with you in this hard hard moment
and i'm gonna pray for your recovery i'm
gonna pray for your family who's still
alive
and i'm going to ask for your blessings
as i continue this hard hard work
and that's going to serve as a miniature
funeral for you if you have a couple of
people at your
station that would do that with you i
think that would be an awesome healing
moment for you guys
but i want you to practice offloading
your bricks
and then go to the gym or just have a
good cry and go for a walk
but i want you to have a a practice i
want you to email me back after 30 days
and let me know if that helped or not
that was a massive thing for me
it was a gift and it was a way that i
could
take those bricks out set them down
acknowledge them
honor them and then go about my the hard
work of putting my waders back on and
going back out there in the sewer
and i want to honor you as a fireman
honor all the first responders all the
folks who show up in the messy
gritty ugliness of other people's lives
but i also want us to also remember that
those folks got to take care of
themselves
they've got to take care of themselves
supervisors
stop with the bravado and the nonsense
if you are a physician supervisor if you
are a
police supervisor if you are a
principal of an elementary school if you
are a business leader
enough look around us
look around us we live in a culture
where we have everything
we have abundance never before known in
the history of time
and we are overweight and exhausted and
anxious and frustrated and depressed
because we have just been told to keep
grinding keep grinding keep grinding do
more do more do more
and guys we are bursting at the seams
we're falling apart from the inside out
and that starts with leadership you want
to model for this
dr andrew young in lubbock texas
and the lubbock police department a
group of people who have taken it upon
themselves
to set up structures for those folks to
be well who have set up structures for
those folks to get the help they need
and also do the right thing who set up
structures for for
training and for teaching
but guys we cannot keep grinding our
helpers down to a nub
teachers are exhausted administrators
are
enough enough i also want to recommend
the book
trauma stewardship by laura vandernutt
lipsky
trauma stewardship by laura vandernutt
lipsky l-i-p-s-k-y it's a very hard book
to read if you are a first responder
it's a difficult it's not re it's not
hard to read because it's a
hard science book it's a hard book to
read because it cut me right in half
it will get in your soul but also give
you some tips on how to continue to keep
yourself well how to create communities
of people who keep themselves well
and how to take care of the people
around you as well so brother ryan
i want to thank you so much again for
your call thanks for letting me rant on
this a little bit this is a
obviously a big deal to me um be wary of
your bell curve make sure you are doing
the things that you need to do to be
well
leaders make sure the people that
report to you are well
man i'm just gonna i'm just gonna be
quiet here
um no no i'm not i'm not um
oh yeah uh james just reminded me the
book's gonna be in the show notes here
um i'm not gonna be quiet about it
i am i am i'm gonna be quiet about it
let's move on i'm just gonna
man i just get fired up about this all
right let's go to kelly in
portland maryland kelly how in the world
are you
i'm doing good how are you john good uh
portland maine sorry about that
and by the way kelly you caught me end
of a rant and so i want you to know
i just exhaled and now it's gone it's
off woo
let's do it kelly what's up great um
well i'm calling
to see if i can get some advice my
husband and i are possibly
thinking about selling our place um our
home now
and moving back closer to my in-laws
okay talk to me about it okay so
we've been married for eight years we
have a two-year-old little girl
um for the first two years that we were
married we
lived next door to my in-laws they have
a
small family farm that my husband grew
up on
and has always worked there it's always
been his dream
to just be there and you know work at
the farm
after two years we decided my
dad passed away and we decided to move
closer
to my family because it was very sudden
and unexpected
and we were just struggling and so we
decided to move
closer to my family and my husband he
was mostly on board but
not a hundred percent i would say and
it's just always been his
dream to move back and be closer to his
family
and so we're kind of just struggling on
coming up with a compromise of where
we land so i i you're using the right
pronoun which is we
we met us to be high-fived and commended
and you are doing the lord's work
talking about how
your husband's heart and mind feels
about things but i also just get this
cascading shadow over your words that
are
you don't want to move the last thing
you want to do is be a farmer's wife
and this whole thing kind of sucks am i
right
um not 100 but yeah yeah
so what's the what's the dilemma are
y'all not talking about it or are you
have y'all reached an impasse is one of
you just gonna have to cave and it's
just gonna be what it is
i think yeah we've talked about it a lot
um
and i guess my biggest thing
is when we were there before
i always felt like i was second and i'm
just really nervous
that that's gonna happen again hmm have
you told him that
yeah um i could probably reiterate it
but
but yes i have in the past so when i
oh man you're the best okay so when i
say have you told him that
when y'all are talking about what it
would look like and he is putting on the
sales pitch for you and he was telling
you but remember this and this is going
to be this way we can get some land
right now
interest rates are low he's giving you
the spiel right um
and you looked at him and said the last
time we lived there
i saw you happy and i felt like i was
number two in your life i feel like i
wasn't valued and it wasn't important
did you say it like that or did you say
i just always you know
how did you say it um
i'm trying to think back here probably
you know i think
i kind of said you know the farm is
first and then i'm number two
what did he say um
you know he agreed that that is kind of
what happened
um but not this time not this time right
right
yes yeah and i mean we we've talked
about you know like he would only work
so many days a week
or whatever um but
i guess i'm i'm just nervous about it
and that
it won't be that way because you know i
get
farm life it depends on whether and
there's animals and there's customers
and you know things are always an
emergency
um but it just being on the other end of
it
kind of sucks to be honest oh totally so
what is a
what's a picture pay me a picture of
what not being number two looks like
what is being number one married to a
farmer look like
i don't really know and so i i think
that's where
the hard work you've got to do is is
that a sentence i just said it sounded
like i said some words out of order
that's the work that you've got to do is
you have to come up
for him and for you what what does it
look like for me to be number one
me to be your wife me to be your your
one and only first
and the cows and sheep second and you've
got to have a firm
like concrete picture of what that looks
like and be able to communicate to that
to him because my guess is you felt like
number two
but that was a secondary feeling too you
just didn't like farming
you didn't like being away from your
family you didn't like
that whatever that life is you didn't
like that and then it ended up feeling
uncomfortable and that became
a way you could see yourself as second
right so it's coming up with some very
concrete pictures of what that looks
like and giving him an opportunity
to live into that or not live into that
and then the second thing is
yeah it's a risk you're right
and your heart and mind is telling you
hey we've already done this it wasn't
good
to use your fancy words it's sucked and
i don't want to go be second to a bunch
of goats again
i don't want to be second to a tractor
again and so
that reality that fear that risk that's
true that's right
there's no question about that
that's not going to go away i guess i
don't i don't know if that's a comfort
to you
there's nothing i can tell you to make
that go away if you're going to move
across the country back to being a
farmer's wife
that's going to be a risk no question
about that i think your
your model for moving forward is how
ironclad is it like how ironclad is that
picture
how how firm on the wall is it and
making sure that you are so clear with
him
so clear i want us to spend breakfast
like this i understand that in this
season
this has to happen i want lunch to look
like this when we can
i want our marriage to look like this we
will have this many dates a week
our kids will look like this but it's
being super super
clear and giving him an opportunity to
speak into that
and it's good to do that before you move
obviously and if you just don't want to
go
be real clear i'm not going to go
because going along part way
and then being bitter about it it's
uh terry real calls it power from the
one down position
it leaves you in a position that all you
can do is be frustrated
all you can do is complain and end up
pulling the boat down
from underneath it right and
if he makes a power move and says we're
going we're i'm the man of this house
and we're going forward
then that's the that's a power from the
one-up position but often folks
can just go all right fine and then
they're not grateful about it they
choose
misery then they choose like oh i'm just
this
whatever and they end up dragging the
ship down slowly from underneath it
and so if you're gonna go make the
absolute best of it
go with full intention go with full plan
make sure you're fully heard your voice
is fully heard your concerns are fully
heard
ways you can hold him accountable to the
shared vision you guys have
make sure that's in place go feeling
empowered
also know going it's going to feel like
a risk you're going to feel weird
because you've been down this road
before and it sucked the last time and
it might suck again
and then the third if you're not going
to go if you're just like i cannot do
this
be real real clear with him because he's
not going to lose you he loves you
he's not going to lose you but don't go
halfway and just drag the whole machine
down
don't go and be like yeah okay it's
going to be great he's going to be
excited and all of a sudden
it's just the relationship is slowly
going to drown so i
mean i i think you do the hard work of
visioning what this could look like
making sure it doesn't look like last
time i think that could be a really
extraordinary moment for you guys
i'd love you to call me back after you
move and you can be like you idiot i
told you
i'm second to the goats that'd be super
fun kelly but i don't think it's gonna
happen i don't think so
all right let's go to leah in grand
rapids michigan
leo what's up hi john how are you
so good how about you i'm doing well
thank you
excellent so here's here's my question
um so i've gone on about eight or nine
dates with this man that i met
online and it's been great good
connection we enjoy each other's company
all that stuff
um fast forward a few weeks i find out
that the first and last name he told me
is actually not his name at all and he's
actually still
legally married and has a child
yeah so at this point i'm not really
sure where to go from here or what
type of conversation or questions i need
to even be asking him
because i feel like i'm kind of caught
in a dilemma of we respond really well
we have good connection
but he's married
this may be my favorite call ever um
it sounds like you super totally know
what to do
but you don't want to how come
i'm just very confused there's no
so there's him hold on there's super no
confusion
um some guy pretended to be somebody he
wasn't
so he could cheat on his wife and did he
say uh
the magic words did he say um we're
getting separated
yes he did yes so awesome so
yeah he's not somebody to be trusted he
is somebody who is
scamming one or both of the women in his
life right now if you all happen to be
the only two
and then he lied about it how'd you find
out
so when he told me his first and last
name i did some investigating
trying to see if like he was on any
social media or whatever and let's be
honest
all good relationships start with an
investigation so go ahead continue
right so i did that couldn't find
anything that's really weird how he's
not showing up on anything
did it again found his like first and
his real first and last name on his
employment site i thought oh wow that's
weird
and it had his picture right next to it
so i knew it was him
this isn't weird this is lying and
deception
you're like wow my house is on fire it
smells smokey
yes it's burning to the ground that's
awesome okay so continue so
you investigate slash stalked him and
then you found out where he worked what
his face looked like he had different
names
and then what happened so i screenshot
it and i
sent it to him and i asked him to
explain did you do that via text
yes i did oh jeez okay so you have a guy
that you're kind of falling for
eight or nine and then you text him
busted then what did he do
and then that's when he gave me the
whole spiel of
well he's legally married but he's going
through a separation
he admitted he does have a daughter and
i asked him
why like why not just be honest
um and he said well i thought you'd
never give me a chance
is that true i mean if he's married then
no i wouldn't give him a chance
i don't want to be dating a married man
okay but you are
and you feel conflicted about it so why
are you conflicted about it
i guess i i'm not really sure what to
even tell the guy because
at this point we have seen each other
since but he didn't bring it up
again so i don't know if i need to be
bringing it up again
i can't imagine this is something he
wants to just talk about all the time
um here's a cool thing you can do um
repeat after me
bye felicia go ahead
bye felicia booyah see that's it
i don't do a lot of good on this podcast
i just did just then
it's it's over the guy is not a
trustworthy person
if is how about this have his wife call
you
and let you know that yes we are indeed
we've been getting separated for a long
time the divorce is just taking some
while because
the lawyers are slowed down because of
the kovids and it's going to be a minute
but yes we are fully separated i
hope he finds happiness enjoy somewhere
else have her call you and then you can
feel free to
just date around the building but
there's no way that's going to happen
right
right i'm super interested in you though
because you've got you sound like you've
got these strong convictions you sound
like you feel totally ripped off but you
have this
um i wish you were having this
conversation in person because i want to
i want to watch you having these
thoughts go through your your mind and
body
you seem conflicted i don't understand
the conflict here
i think the conflict comes into place
because he
seemed at the beginning like a very
genuine person
he has his life together so i i guess i
never would have thought that someone
like him would do something like this
ah there you go so here's an ugly
crappy part of somebody lying to you
like this or getting cheated on
is not only is there a hurt that someone
deceived you
but you stop trusting you
right you've got to grieve the fact that
you missed it
or that he seemed like dot dot or she
felt like dot dot dot
if you go back in well that's not a i
was gonna i was gonna compare him to
jeffrey dahmer and that's probably a
little bit not fair but if you go back
and read some of those things the guy
was a lovely wonderful guy
everyone liked being around him he was
fun and everyone said i couldn't believe
that dot
dot now of course this dude isn't a mass
murderer and all that
so that wasn't fair but yes people all
the time think
i can't believe that they fill in the
blank and
the disorienting part about that is that
you have to look in the mirror and say
how did i miss that
what is it about me that missed that i
thought i was smart i thought i was
could read people
i thought that was my thing and that
sucks have you
spent some time just realizing this
sucks
this isn't fun yes yeah how'd that go
i was pretty bummed out because in a the
last relationship i was in it was the
same type of scenario where he lied
about having his kid
and then the baby mama contacted me and
told me
yeah so it's just weird that it the same
things keep happening
where it's the dishonesty yeah what apps
are you using
don't tell me but maybe that's a good
place to start
with whatever apps you're you're finding
folks on right
um why did you see him again
after you busted him and he told you
this stuff and then you got back
together you all met up
and then it didn't really come up
and you probably had some imaginary
conversations in your head about what
you were going to say to him when you
finally saw him
and you were just going to wait till he
told you and he didn't say anything and
y'all just
went on with your date and then he just
dropped you off and you went home
and then you were just kind of like
how did you feel going through that time
that space
it was very awkward yeah why didn't you
bring something up
because i didn't really even know how to
bring it up
okay ready i'm gonna teach you
um and that's not even going to be by
felicia this is another one
um let's see how we can do this directly
yes i got it
why did you lie to me
and then he'll be like no no no why did
you lie to me
we went out eight or nine times and i
was honest with you and i told you some
things about me i was vulnerable with
you and i said i liked you
and you didn't mention anything about
having a kid you didn't mention
anything about being currently married
like why'd you lie to me i liked you
that's how you do that
okay and if in your
gut you know he's not telling you the
truth
don't leah you're like you're worth not
being lied to and you're worth not being
cheated on you're worth somebody telling
you the truth
yeah that's true you are and i don't
even care what happened when you were
ten years ago and eight years ago and fi
you're just worth not being lied to
here's the other thing maybe his story
is true
it might totally be true and
he needs an opportunity to turn around
come super clean
and to say i i freaked out i thought you
would never talk to me this whole
thing's been a mess
i lied to you and that sucks and i
screwed up and i'm sorry
i i just think very few people are not
redeemable
but it starts with people looking
somebody that they love in the eye
something they like in the eye and say
i screwed up real bad i'm sorry
but if you're just going to go see him
tomorrow then you've got to make peace
with you know what
i used to say i wasn't going to date a
married man i'm cool with it
i'm cool with it i thought i wouldn't be
the kind of person that dated a married
man but
it's all good and that may be where part
of your conflict is coming from
i wouldn't recommend that but hey if
that's
if if that's what your some of your
struggles come from that's where some of
your struggles coming from i don't think
so
i think you're tired of people lying to
you and they're not little lying to you
like i love your
cooking and it's not that great they're
not that's not those kind of lies
it's oh yeah i'm still married oh yeah
i've got kids oh yeah fill in the blank
those are big
and you're slowly giving your heart away
trying to be vulnerable trying to
fall in love with somebody and they're
not being honest that hurts and that
sucks
so i'm sorry but i also want you to
trust you i want you to stand firm in
your values and stand
firm in the things that you think are
right and if somebody pulls a big one on
you like that have the courage to look
at them and say why did you lie to me
answer that question we're not going to
go out anymore i'm not going to hold
your hand anymore we're not going to
kiss anymore
why did you lie to me
and if they give you an answer that's
shenanigans and it's just a box of
doodoo bombs then just walk away and
you're going to be lonely it's going to
hurt it's going to suck but walk away
tell the truth even when you do
something that's not smart
not right tell the truth folks good
grief leah thank you so much for that
call
let me know how the final the bye
felicia goes i'm interested to know
how that final conversation goes and
somebody create an app for great people
i'm sure that exists somewhere i don't
have any apps i
create an app for people to meet each
other especially now on the covets all
right let's take one more call let's go
to
nathaniel in columbia south carolina
what's up nathaniel
hey how's the next big uh talk show
personality doing
right i keep telling everybody that we
only have like 42 people who listen to
this podcast but we're going to get
there brother we're going to get there
ah you're a star in the making how are
you man
well i can't complain a lot going on but
i think that describes most of us so
you know i'm not going to complain very
cool so what's up brother how can i help
well i noticed that there's a lot of
i would call impulsive behaviors not
major things but
that i have a habit of
doing and it's affecting my life in
small ways and i just
want to know get some advice on how to
control them better
very cool so talk to me about the
impulsive behaviors
well i can think of a few things in gen
in particular one uh a little bit of
overeating i wouldn't consider myself
like
an overweight person so it's a little
bit hard to talk with people about it
but um for instance if i'm at my
my work i'll visit the snack machine
on good days three times hello
yeah i love snack machines man i'm with
you yeah
yeah uh on bad days where i'm stress
eating it's
five-ish which is not or six i don't
know
uh so that's one thing and then now that
i'm working from home a little bit more
you know oh look at 10 30 i guess it's
time for lunch number three already
that's right that's right oh that's one
thing and another
area i notice is uh internet time okay
especially during work
uh so a lot of my work right now is on
my laptop
and uh i get distracted really easy
watching youtube
um it's kind of frustrating and uh
so yeah so besides eating
and some internet distractions what else
something else is is behind you
something's worrying you what is that
i mean other things is i think it's more
omissions like okay i should be
exercising
but let's watch one more episode of the
john galone show before i go and
five hours later always okay always okay
so sacrifice your physical i'm not what
i'm trying to no
kidding um or just our stuff like oh
i guess it's time to you know uh clean
that
you know jenga tower of dirty dishes in
my sink right now but i'll get to it
it's just irritating stuff like that uh
and i guess what's compounding it a
little bit
is one in about three weeks i'm getting
married oh
okay i i i told my fiance about this is
that like
i think i'm a little disappointed in
myself that i imagined i would be a
different person
by this point or like you know i've i've
been trying to change the behaviors like
okay make a schedule
start putting ad block or not ad blocker
site blockers on your computer
uh stop carrying money to work so you
can't
you know actually buy anything uh you
know and that works for
a week or so and then a distraction or
stress
happens i resort to those as control
mechanisms
back to square one gotcha okay
so what would you say brother is at the
root of
your you call them impulsive behaviors
um they're those are
really numbing behaviors they are
ways to unplug real quick or
for a long time and usually those
behaviors are rooted in some sort of
of underlying stress underlying feelings
of
what's what's underlying for you man
uh one thing i guess that comes to mind
a lot
is uh my research i'm a i'm a grad
student getting my phd
good for you and i mean i tell people
this quite frankly uh i think my
research is
a burning dumpster fire within a train
wreck
within a meteor crater yes um
what are you studying i mean i'm i'm
starting organic chemistry
oh that sounds exciting okay you
actually could literally be studying
inside of a dumpster fire though which
is pretty cool for oak him
um why do you say your research is no
good
uh well i feel like well just talking to
my
advisor i it's
i my last three projects kind of
i worked on it really hard and it turned
essentially my advisor said scrap this
project go somewhere else
um and that's been the case for
the last few years like i'm i mean i'm
still in the program so
hooray uh and i'm more than halfway
past the halfway point thankfully but uh
a lot of times i don't know if my
advisor is just being a perfectionist
or if i'm actually and he's just i'm
actually doing okay
and he's just trying to push me harder
or it's
you should be really worried right now
and you need to
you know shift gears and i guess
also with
the whole the big news that's happening
around the world coronavirus
uh i got placed back on ta duty
it's a whole lot more work online
everything is slower
and i just spend most of my time grading
papers as opposed to actual research
yep but that doesn't help the situation
uh how how old are you man that's 25
okay can you um
let's get in a
let's just back up for a second okay can
you go global with me for a second
okay you're getting married in a few
weeks the world is
literally and figuratively on fire
we're in the middle of a pretty
remarkable pandemic
an absolute economic implosion
you are in the middle of one of the most
difficult ph
phd programs on the planet
real hard a lot of people do a lot of
gymnastics academically to get out of
ochem and you're getting a phd in it
it's hard what you're doing most people
who aren't in the phd process
don't know how many times you feel real
good about something and your advisor
says that's not good enough do that
again
that happened to me a bunch or rewrite
this
or where did you even get this
information from you need to redo that
again
and my advisors both of them were really
wonderful people
and i still had to redo some stuff
you are in the middle of three of the
most stressful things i can imagine
were you going to school to be a
professor too
uh yes okay so you're also in the middle
of a
you're working towards a career that is
evolving
and changing underneath us all at as we
speak here right
so you are living literally in a true
dumpster fire
everything around you is on fire and one
of the things our brains do
is they love us and try to take care of
us
and so what you've got is a series of
behaviors whether
we can call them little ticks you can
call them little whatevers
which are little mini checkout moments
i'm just going to click off i can't read
one more stupid okay and paper i'm just
going to spend the next four hours here
i'm going to procrastinate on this i'm
going to just have one more meal
because i need one more dopamine hit
that's going to make that stress a
little bit
less it's going to cover up my amygdala
a little bit more right it's going to
unhook it a little bit more
and i want you to number one first and
foremost give yourself some grace
okay you are in
the middle of it it's a lot going on
i also want you to
real like i'm not big on shoulds and
have to's i think some shoulds and i
wish i had
those can weigh people down but you've
got to stop
talking to nathan so badly okay
you are beating up nathan you're talking
to yourself in a way that you would
never let somebody talk to your fiance
right right is that fair
i think that's fair okay so distraction
behaviors
are they're they're just a bomb they're
like chapstick
they're a lie okay think of them like a
lie
um the key here if you want to change
the behavior number one is awareness
when you're about to eat something when
you're about to go to the snack machine
as you start to roll your chair back
because it happens automatically right
i want you to or at your house when you
decide oh man
it's time for first seventh lunch
i want you to pause and say what am i
trying to protect myself from
and just let it sit there for a second
as you're about to eat another sleeve of
cookies i want you to think
huh why am i still eating this
what is my brain trying to protect me
from and it's probably from one more
assignment
one more place where you're gonna not
feel enough
one more step towards a job that you
don't even know if it's gonna be there
one more step towards a forever decision
which is getting married
right it's doing its job it's trying to
protect you and what you have to do is
fill your your resiliency bucket if you
will
with positive behaviors instead of
default settings
and so just getting rid of impulsive
behaviors just stopping eating
or just saying i want to be super good
looking for my wedding
i want to be super good for my professor
those are always going to be trying to
fill an internal hole with external
plugs you're going to be doing something
for somebody else for somebody else for
somebody else
and i want you to begin talking to
nathan in a positive way
she began to say i'm going to eat well
because i'm going to feel better my
research is going to be better
i'm going to be able to be a better
husband for my wife
my head's going to be better not just so
i'm not fat
you know what i mean going towards
something instead of away from something
is totally different
and just recognizing your impulses are
liars
let me give you a sentence that changed
my life
okay i struggle with impulse behaviors
a lot i've got a lot of tics i've
struggled with adhd my whole life and
with anxiety my whole life
and i read a sentence that was from an
adhd scholar that was really
extraordinary for me
and here was the sentence don't forget
to remember
and i know it sounds out of order in a
wacky sentence
don't forget to remember here's what
that sentence means
it means when i pull up to my house i
for some reason i can't see i still have
cds in my car
i can't see the cds that are scattered
all over my car i can't see the water
bottles
and the um you know the lacroix cans in
the car i don't i just don't see it
but i remember what it feels like
getting into a really messy truck
i remember what it feels like to get
into a really clean truck
i forget i'll walk through the house and
i will just leave
crap everywhere i will wake up and think
i don't want to go work out downstairs
and then i will make sure i don't forget
to remember how good it feels after i've
worked out
how good it feels to actually put stuff
away where it goes
and what it does is it takes me to the
other end not on the front end because
people who struggle with impulse
behavior who struggle with numbing
behaviors who struggle with addiction
who struggle with adhd on the front end
they they struggle with that front end
impulse
what we can control is the back end okay
what we can control
is where we're headed
i don't want to pick that stuff up now
but i don't want to forget to remember
how good it feels
when the house is clean when i how good
it feels when my wife can just relax and
smile because she's worked her butt off
with our kids but
all day and so don't forget to remember
as a sentence that changed my life i
hope it will change yours
i want to tell you man you are in the
middle of it this storm will pass
winter will pass and spring will come
your wedding's going to be awesome
she said she loved you before you
started working out
so she still loves you i don't want you
to work out for her i want you to work
out for you
i don't want you to try to get the next
right phd program for your professor
to try to prove that you belong you do
you got in the program i want you to
work really hard on your research
because we need some great ochem people
out there we got a lot of problems that
ocem folks can help us solve
i want you to do it because you can do
it i want you to
not spend time on the internet brother
because i want you to get your grading
done so you can go outside and go for a
walk
so you can go outside and call your
fiance and you're gonna talk about
what's gonna happen four or five years
from now
because you're worth it brother
nathaniel thank you so much for the call
that's the show today
as we leave man sometimes we talk about
the greatest song of all times and
we talk about the greatest song by the
greatest singer of all time
i'm gonna be honest with you that's not
today today we're going to
talk about a pretty good singer from a
pretty good record
sometimes singer's not that great
and the song's not that great but it
just
sticks in your soul and it won't
freaking leave
so here i am this many years later
about to read the song that came at 1990
off the record soul provider by the one
and only
king mullet himself michael bolton
the song is how am i supposed to live
without you
i don't know michael i don't know but
i'm still singing that song
this many years later it goes like this
i could hardly believe it when i heard
the news today i had come
i had to come and get it straight from
you they said you were leaving
someone swept your heart away from the
look upon your face i
i see it's true so tell me about it tell
me about the plans you're making
tell me one more thing before i go
tell me how am i supposed to live
without you now that i've been loving
you
so long how am i supposed to live
without you how am i supposed to carry
on
when all that i've been living for is
gone i don't know michael
i don't know how we're supposed to carry
on there's only so much we can do here
on the dr john dolone show